vous isabelle moi j'ai jamais été ivres
de ma vie c'est vraiment vous voulez
tout le temps elle atteint dix mille
habitants
elle est tombée dans une bouteille de
rhum côté petit déjà j'ai essayé de
retenir une fois un petit copain qui
faisait un mètre quatre-vingt dix-huit
et dans les trois quarts du corps et est
par dessus le balcon
donc je n'arrivais pas à le retenir on a
vraiment failli partir tous les deux
ouais et alors seulement je les lis 20
ans elle est décédée
et quand on voit ce que j'ai continué ma
vie celle elles sont prêtes les canaris
ont dit ces cas roger qui veulent mourir
mais c'est bon on continue la chômage ya
trois semaines je n'étais pas au volant
c'était ma femme on s'est fait arrêter
par les gendarmes et le vent elle m'a
dit vous avez bu elle a dit oui bien sûr
trois verres de gnôle et m'a dit ok
d'accord que c'est ce qu'elle a compris
que c'était de l'humour c'est sympa
écoutez bravo
[Applaudissements]